keep going
the Russian government says it's willing
to negotiate
but the Russian military has decided to
bomb
this is harkive Ukraine's second largest
city as filmed Through the Windows of
its residents
shakes and it shudders under a fiery
barrage
the attacks seem indiscriminate
it was a bloody day the government says
dozens of people have been killed
in the north the city of chernohev has
been targeted by artillery and by
missile strikes too a popular shopping
center was hit and a residential
building was partially destroyed the
Ukrainian government said there was an
unknown number of casualties
in the South the Russians have taken
ground securing the city hall in
berjansk
rain's residents did not cower instead
they faced the enemy and told them to go
home
such confrontations have been replicated
around the country
[Music]
as the attack on Ukraine intensifies the
parties met for talks on the border of
Belarus
but there seems little Prospect of
success the Russians began the day
complaining the ukrainians were late
we've been waiting all night to talk
while their civilians are dying said
their delegation's head
the besuited Russians here on the left
said little about their aims while the
ukrainians have demanded an immediate
cease-fire their President Vladimir
zielinski seeks salvation in the west
and sees his country's future in the EU
we asked the European Union to admit
Ukraine immediately under a new special
procedure we are grateful to our
partners for fighting with us but our
goal is to be together with all
Europeans later he signed an application
for membership and posted it online
as the Russians press forward the
ukrainians sign up here registering for
the Army in the city of danipro we were
asked not to show their faces
so many people have put themselves
forward the authorities are turning them
away many are now making Molotov
cocktails instead
their Commander says he's inspired
um
foreign
in Western Ukraine now stands as a
beacon of sorts offering passage to
Poland by train
and tens of thousands on a seat so in
the late everything could come so me and
my kids
have traveled to Poland first I don't
know which way now we're gonna try
because it's really hard to do now and
then we're gonna go to Germany
it is a difficult Journey fueled by
anxiety and disbelief and their return
beset by uncertainty
[Music]
takes courage to stay put in cities like
Kiev as the Russians deploy the might of
their military machine
they will not sleep in the Ukrainian
Capital but the majority seem prepared
to defend it
John Sparks Sky News in Ukraine